[Musique]
J'en ai marre que les gens me disent
que l'Amérique est le plus grand pays
parce que nous pouvons te fouetter le cul Je déteste certaines
de ces personnes mais je n'ai jamais tué
[Applaudissements]
comment gérez-vous cela, vous n'êtes jamais
va pouvoir ne pas voir ce que tu as vu essayer
de destituer tu essaies juste et tu
auras un spasme de violence dans ce pays
comme si tu n'avais jamais vu le
gouverneur Snyder J'ai de l'eau de silex
pour toi
[Musique]
si personne ne va le faire alors je  je dois le
faire alors je vais vous donner vous êtes je vais
vous combattre dans la foutue rue en ce moment d'
accord comment cela s'est-il passé le rêve américain
est mort arrêtez de résister
[Applaudissements]
les pouvoirs du président ici sont au-delà de la
collection mesdames et messieurs le dernier
président de  les États-Unis
[Musique]
venir dans une ville américaine près de chez vous
vous